knowing that it is a crime to lie to
congress do you wish to retract your
statement of may 11 where you claimed
that the nih never funded gain of
function research in wuhan senator paul
i have never lied before the congress
and i do not retract
that statement and if anybody is lying
here senator it is you
hmm almost as mad at rand paul as he was
he was at the
games over the weekend so in short look
rand paul was right fauci did lie to
congress because new documents obtained
by the intercept show that taxpayer
money from fauci's niid
was funneled to the eco health alliance
run by peter dashak and it studied the
risk of bat coronavirus emergence in
wuhan now part of the proposal admits
how dangerous all of it was
saying fieldwork involves the highest
risk of exposure to sars or other
coronaviruses while working in caves
with high bat density overhead and the
potential for fecal dust to be inhaled
rutgers molecular biologist richard e
bright summed it up saying the materials
confirm that the grant supported the
construction in wuhan of naval
sars-related coronaviruses that combine
a spike gene from one coronavirus with a
genetic information from another
coronavirus and confirm the resulting
viruses could infect human cells the
documents make it clear that assertions
by collins and fauci that the nih did
not support gain of function research or
potential pandemic pathogen enhancement
at wuhan are untruthful that's a
mouthful but we had to say it joining me
now is senator tom cotton who was the
first politician to raise the lab leak
theory over 18 months ago senator
your take on these new documents
well laura i've said for months that
tony fauci should be fired now it's
clear they lied to congress so she he
should be investigated and prosecuted to
the fullest extent of the law you know
for 18 months he's been saddling up his
moral high horse and clucking his tongue
at college kids who want to go celebrate
a football game in an outdoor stadium on
a nice full day or parents who don't
want their kindergartners to have to
wear masks their entire lives telling
you you have to wear three masks when
all along he's been lying not just to
congress but to the american people
about his role in funding the very
reckless dangerous research at a chinese
communist lab that unleashed this
pandemic on the world it is a disgrace
and it's time for tony fauchy to be held
accountable if you had to rate this as a
scandal
what would you rate it as senator
one of the biggest scandals in
washington modern times i mean
it funded a laboratory that in all
likelihood is the source of this once in
a century pandemic that has upended so
many of our lives
hundreds of thousands of people dead
many more have been seriously ill kids
have lost a year now going on a second
year of their education
weddings have been postponed
jobs have been lost businesses have been
closed and tony fauci all along has been
lecturing you while hiding the fact that
without
proper notification to his political
superiors in the executive branch funded
this reckless dangerous research in a
chinese communist lab and then
and then went to great lengths to try to
excuse them i always wondered why early
on in the pandemic tony fauci insisted
there was no way this virus could have
come from that lab it's not just obvious
common sense it broke out just blocks
away from the lab where they're studying
the coronavirus where the lady in charge
is nicknamed the bat lady yet he always
insisted couldn't be possible well now
we know it was to cover his own tracks
it was to conceal what he had done with
your tax dollars in incredibly reckless
research in a chinese communist lab
what will happen in the senate next
senator
well i for one am going to be looking
forward to tony fauci's next appearance
in the united states senate now it's no
longer just tony fauci trying to lecture
senators using word games acting like
they're the dumb ones like they're the
ones who don't understand basic concepts
like making a virus more transmissible
when now it's in his own words and his
own emails and the emails all of his
cronies who've been on this gravy train
for decades getting your tax dollars and
then concealing what it went for so i
for one am looking forward to tony
fauci's next appearance from the united
states senate his appearance after that
should be at the federal courthouse down
the street how much legal jeopardy is in
is he in uh from one to ten ten being
the most legal jeopardy
well if he were a trump appointee laura
it would be an 11. let's just say it
that way i mean he plainly lied to
congress and it is time for the
department of justice to investigate
tony fauci and to hold him accountable
to the fullest extent of the law there
is no way you can get around the fact
that he has been misleading congress
repeatedly in addition to misleading the
american people for a year and a half
while he's con presumed to lecture them
about all their moral failings and
stopping spreading this virus from a lab
that he helped fund
senator thank you and he told us we
couldn't travel this weekend that was
would have been a bad idea to travel
this weekend oh please hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else